6 25 on your friday morning what's cool
at school how about a career day
on wheels
while all elementary school career days
include great conversations about what
grownups do
along with tap dancing around questions
about how much you get paid what kind of
car you drive
but not many career days include mobile
news bands or police officers with their
motorcycles
ron futrell and i talked to hundreds of
students at john hubbell the other day
not only explaining how the eight news
now van gets the news to you from just
about anywhere but also showing the
students the computer video screens and
all the buttons knobs and dials that
make it happen we even did a decent job
of making some of them feel like part of
the eight news now team
[Music]
a lot of fun out there also at that
career day there were firefighters in
full gear attacking a wrecked car to
show the life rescue process there's a
fedex truck and a driver a construction
crane and operator thanks to hummel for
having all of us out there if you know
something cool at school just let us
know cool it's cool under the
communitytab at
or email cool at school at 8newsnow.com